العراق يريد خروجا سريعا ومنظما لقوات
التحالف الدولي الذي تقوده الولايات
المتحده بهذه الكلمات دعا رئيس الوزراء
العراقي شياع السوداني القوات الامريكيه
الى مغادره بلاده وهذه ليست المره الاولى
التي تتعالى فيها الاصوات المطالبه
بانسحاب تلك القوات اذ سبق ان طالب
البرلمان صراحه بطرد القوات الاجنبيه من
البلاد قبل ان تتعالى تلك الاصوات بعد
السابع من اكتوبر
لماذا دخلت القوات الامريكيه
للعراق دخلت قوات التحالف بزعامه امريكا
العراق عام 2003 بحجه وجود اسلحه دمار
شامل ومحاربه الارهاب وتحرير الشعب
العراقي قبل ان تبدا بالانسحاب منه
تدريجيا عام 2008 على اثر اتفاقيه امنيه
وقعتها واشنطن مع بغداد وبمقتضاها اتمت
امريكا انسحابها في عام 2011 لكن سيطره
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه على مدينه الموصل
في عام
2014 وانهيار القوات العراقيه في الاشهر
الاخيره من الحكومه الثانيه لنور المالكي
دفع رئيس الحكومه انذاك حيدر العبادي الى
العوده الى واشنطن وطلب المساعده الجويه
واللوجستيه العاجله لحمايه العراق وشعبه
الامر الذي ادى بطبيعه الحال الى عوده
القوات الامريكيه الى البلاد وكان الهدف
منها تدريب الجيش العراقي وتوفير غطاء جوي
لقوات الامن والفصائل المسلحه التي حاربت
التنظيم الى ان نجحت الحكومه في استرداد
السيطره على جميع الاراضي بين عامي
و27 لكن مع ذلك ظلت واشنطن تحتفظ بجنود
لها في العراق وتختلف التقديرات في
الاعداد الدقيقه للجنود الاجانب ويشير
بعضها الى ان هنا هناك نحو 2500
جندي لماذا تبقي امريكا قواتها في العراق
رغم انتهاء عملياتها القتاليه الرسميه في
عام
2019 اعلن الرئيس الامريكي السابق ترامب
ان واشنطن ستواصل الابقاء على جنودها في
العراق لمراقبه جارته ايران ويرى ستيف
سايمون استاذ دراسات الشرق الاوسط بجامعه
واشنطن ان هناك فوائد ماديه للولايات
المتحده في حصولها على خامات من العراق
وفائده استراتيجيه للعراق في عدم عوده
تنظيم الدوله بالاضافه الى تحقيق توازن مع
ايران ولا سما في ظل وجود كثير من
العراقيين الذين يفضلون الهيمنه الامريكيه
على الايرانيه تنص الماده 30 من الاتفاقيه
الامنيه على انه لا يحق انهاء الاتفاقيه
دون اتفاق الطرفين كما يجب على كل طرف
ابلاغ الاخر برغبته في الالغاء قبل عام من
الطلب وان يكون حق طلب الالغاء للقائد
العام للقوات المسلحه يرى خبراء ان سحاب
القوات الامريكيه من العراق مرهون بيد
قيادات القوات المسلحه وان على الحكومه ان
تلتزم بالتفاوض وديا من اجل تحقيق ذلك كي
تناى بنفسها عن عقوبات اقتصاديه محتمله قد
تفرضها
امريكا
ه